in the last week of August 2022
ukrainians launched their maturated
counter-offensive in the Harrison region
aiming to retake it along with its
Regional Center Harrison City Russian
propagandists and Military bloggers
initially tried to downplay the events
writing about thousands of Ukrainian
soldiers killed 400 of all Ukrainian
hymers launchers destroyed and so on but
then ukrainians broke through the first
line of defense and started liberating
settlements it's been about two weeks
since they started and their momentum
does not seem to have slowed down in
fact ukrainians begin another surprise
offensive in the Orchid region where
they absolutely decimated the unprepared
and under-equipped Russians why is this
extremely important because we have
reason to believe that this operation is
the beginning of the end for Russia and
not just their military but potentially
the modern Russian state so on the
occasion of the 200th day of Russia's
three-day special military operation
let's review the current situation and
its awesome implications including the
eventual reduction of energy bills in
Europe with that being said allow me to
quickly pay mine as power coaster
hitting historic highs and as a result
we've seen a flurry of government action
to try and handle the crisis now
normally people's income compassive
Investments could help ease the pain of
the cost of living crisis but
unfortunately Goldman Sachs reports that
a typical stock heavy portfolio is
expected to Flatline at best this year
and so what do you do when inflation is
making your savings a bad list to keep
money as well well you could put it into
Investments outside of the stock market
no not a save for a pillow I'm talking
Safe Haven assets like Fine Art and
that's where today's sponsor Masterworks
comes in it basically works like this
the company Masterworks buys up an
expensive art piece then breaks it up to
smaller affordable shares which you can
then invest in on their platform this is
actual fine art from guys like Picasso
and Banksy not an nft don't worry
according to delawad 85 percent of
wealth managers believe there's an
argument for art as part of a wealth
offering even Morgan Stanley
specifically recommended Fine Art saying
investment grade art has a low
correlation to other major asset classes
and often experiences lower price
volatility also contemporary art has for
the past 25 years outpaced the S P 500
by more than double and during times of
Crisis it can actually appreciate even
more just look at covid Contemporary
Arts appreciation spiked from 13.8 for
the last 25 years 20 whopping 25 percent
no wonder that during our current crisis
Masterworks is seeing increased demand
from investors looking to get
Contemporary Art into their portfolios
as Masterworks removes the multi-million
dollar price tag Masterworks has over
500 000 users and since having started
out in 2017 they've been featured on
TechCrunch CNBC and Forbes among others
and today they've sold six paintings for
an average unit return of 29 of course
past performance is no guarantee for
future results but that's still pretty
incredible demand is high with the stock
market still in turmoil and there is a
waiting list but my viewers can skip it
by using my link in the description
thank you for checking out Masterworks
as like this helps with what I do and
now back to the video
at the end of August ukrainians launched
their long-awaited hairson
counter-offensive this wasn't your
regular offensive though with large
concentrated forces and sweeping
Maneuvers that is a surprise tool that
would help Ukraine later it was preceded
by what Philips O'Brien calls the battle
of the bridges where ukrainians with the
help of highmars systematically
destroyed the andonitsky road bridge and
the novakovka road and rail Bridge these
forced the Russians to use fairies
across the river but there's a problem
throughout the summer ukrainians have
been loud and clear about the
counter-offensive starting any day now
Russians therefore pulled a massive
Force to the right Bank of the nipple
River why were you gradients so vocal
about their intentions looks like they
shot themselves in the foot by giving
the game away right not quite see the
bridges were still up when Russia pulled
their large Force to the right bank and
large forces need large amounts of
supplies fairies alone cannot handle
such volume but by the time Russians
were in place the bridges were disabled
forcing Russians to use fairies causing
an almost immediate Supply shortage
shortly after ukrainians began their
counter-offensive in earners in three
major directions within the Harrison
region as I've mentioned this isn't a
large scale sweeping maneuver across the
landscape like in the movies rather
according to Ukrainian officials the
goal is to gradually isolate the
undersupplied Russian forces and then
wear them down causing them to collapse
and Retreat rinse and repeat the
ukrainian's task is not easy though
despite supply issues Russians still
pose a formidable threat in the area due
to sheer numbers and they've also built
three lines of Defense in the northwest
of Herson ukrainians are moving towards
the city itself Village by Village here
they have managed to break through the
Russian's first line of defense almost
immediately and now the second as well
it seems ukrainians likely don't want to
lay a Siege on Harrison City as that
would result in a second Mario poll
rather the goal is likely to have
Russians collapse on all of their fronts
and have them flee across the river
giving up Hairston without Urban Warfare
to the Northeast around ww breed
ukrainians have created a wedge deep
into Russian occupied territory they are
likely after the main road near the
wedge used to resupply Russian troops
further north east the more the wedge
widens and advances the bigger the
trouble will be for Russians up
Northeast in the north ukrainians are
rolling downward gradually taking back
Village after Village the goal of the
Hearthstone counter offensive is of
course to take back everything on the
nepro reverse ride bank but it also has
a lesser known but very practical side
effect if and when Russian defenses
collapse and demoralized exhausted
Russian troops flee across the river all
they will have is a few small ferries to
do so meaning they'll have to leave
behind most of their equipment
especially heavy Vehicles meaning
Christmas will come early to the
Ukrainian armed forces in the South also
they will get their washing machines
back from abandoned Russian positions
but as you might have heard the Harrison
counteroffensive wasn't the only one
around the 6th of September ukrainians
also began a sweeping lightning
offensive in the horkie region which
appears to have caught the Russians by
complete surprise according to Philips
O'Brien this means the Russian army is
in severe disarray for Ukraine to
achieve a surprise this close to Russian
border would otherwise be virtually
impossible at the time of making this
video ukrainians have taken back almost
everything west of the Oscar River
including Russian strongholds like
bolaclia and izum and their soul
Logistics Lifeline kupiansk Justin
polaclia hundreds of Russian troops got
trapped including sobrespetsnaz units
those troops have now either fled or
died we even have footage of a Russian
plane getting hit by air defenses in
that area otherwise there are reports of
multiple down Russian planes and
helicopters Ukrainian air defense solid
so the Russian Air Force cannot come to
the rescue there is also footage of
horrified russian-speaking ukrainians
quivering in fear as the age of Neo-Nazi
NATO Bandera super soldier hordes
arrived to oppress them they are so
afraid in fact that they cannot help but
cry and hug the Ukrainian soldiers in
their Terror they also stand next to the
road and wave and cheer at passing
Ukrainian convoys that manual there is
so shocked and horrified that he is
already practicing kneeling for his
impending execution for being a Russian
speaker the horkie of country offensive
seems to have been made possible by
Russians pulling their troops South in
anticipation of the Hearthstone
counter-offensive meaning Ukraine
managed to play Russia not on one but
two fronts consequently the undermanned
and under equipped Russian formations in
the archive region have collapsed
completely this is a textbook route one
that will have severe consequences for
the Russians meanwhile pro-russian
propaganda this time bloggers are in
varying stages of grief a funny
phenomenon was official Russian
propaganda clashing with veteran
military bloggers where propaganda said
everything was okay while veteran
accounts were screaming at them to get
real because Russian lines are
collapsing as of the making of this
video there are increasing rumors about
ukrainians having made all the way to
lesachansky and to Donetsk airport there
are additional reports suggesting
ukrainians have crossed the Oscar River
and are about to take sotope from where
Russians retweeted this would indicate
the nearly complete collapse of the
Russian military in the area and the
doyas kellogan's colonial militias DPR
leader Denis pushilin has in fact fled
from doyesque City putting out a
situation update from the back seat of a
car running full speed on a country road
if I was a Toyota Colonial militia
member now would be the time for me to
start worrying and the most [ __ ] up
part Russia seems to have closed the
borders for occupied dombast civilians
wanting to flee to Russia keep in mind
these are the people who have been
living under Russian occupation since
2014 and for eight years they've been
told that the Ukrainian bonded O'Neill
Nazis are coming to genocide them for
speaking Russian I can only imagine
what's going through the heads of those
people right now but this should serve
as ample proof that Russia never
actually cared about donbass civilians
welcome to the Russian World and all
this Ukrainian military success will
have severe short mid and long-term
implications for Russia both militarily
and politically first off they lost a
whole lot of territory band and
Equipment if Maria was bad already now
it's bound to be catastrophic this is
also a huge also face for the supposed
second army in the world and a massive
PR win for ukrainians second this will
mean more weapons shipments to Ukraine
since now it's clear that if you give
ukrainians modern Western weapons they
will deliver results their success is
also dull Western far-right isolationist
criticism of supporting Ukraine it also
reinforces critics of the war inside
Russia both on the citizen and the
leadership level and there's virtually
nothing pushing can do to change this
situation his energy blackmail hand is
already fully played having cut off gas
to Europe completely and Europe is doing
all right all things considered enormous
efforts have been made and are being
made to replace Russian gas and decrease
gas use in general and once you get off
gas replacing it with electricity or
geothermal there is no going back to it
Europe will cease to be a market for
Russian gas of which only a fraction can
be sold to China and India due to
pipeline limitations meanwhile the
Russian military as a whole is stuck in
a quagmire they are simply too weakened
and demoralized to conduct any major
offensives from now on they are stuck on
the defensive trying to fend off
Ukrainian attacks on multiple fronts
with less and less people and
progressively older equipment and Putin
cannot even declare General mobilization
to try and reinforce his army I mean he
could but he would be an absolute fool
to do so the infrastructure for Mass
mobilization doesn't exist anymore and
he'd be breaking the unspoken contracts
with the Russian population the war
remains a distant event they only see on
TV and in exchange They Don't Rock the
Boat meanwhile sanctions are hurting the
Russian economy significantly if they
didn't Russia wouldn't demand lifting
them in exchange for restarting gas
utilized to Europe Putin has no way out
if he pulls out his nationalist base
will turn against him if he stays in his
army and economy will be gradually
strangled when things reach a Breaking
Point when The Invasion Force collapses
and domestic discontent reaches critical
levels when the oligarchic ruling class
turns against Putin the existence of
modern Russia itself will be at risk
especially as Vladimir zelenski has
recently signaled that Crimea is also on
the table if ukrainians took over some
of it or even all of it that would
destroy Vladimir Putin's Crown Jewel
achievement and his most important claim
to power his annexation of Crimea and if
ukrainians managed to roll over Russians
in the South Crimea will be wide open
there is no Russian backup for a station
there everything they have is already
deployed ukrainians achieving accessing
Crimea will be the end of Vladimir Putin
after that we can likely expect the
collapse of the current Russian power
structure which could very well result
in the country's dissolution to
disparate regions controlled by local
strongmen and oligarchs it would be the
undoing of centuries of Russian
imperialism and I for one cannot wait at
any rate one thing is for certain the
coming months won't be fun for the
Russians so expect more good news out of
Ukraine and the more footage of the [ __ ]
show the Russians got their special
military operation and I thank you for
watching don't forget to like And
subscribe and I also have a patreon if
you think this content is worth your
money and I'll be seeing you next time